tchernobyl rien n'est réglé après
l'accident de la centrale nucléaire les
autorités soviétiques reconnaissent
maintenant qu'ils se trouvent devant des
problèmes jamais affrontés par le passé
la radioactivité recommencent à
augmenter dans la région de kiev dans
cette ville il semble bien qu un début
de panique pousse ses habitants à
quitter la ville il y aurait même eu des
empoisonnements aux médicaments dans
cette ville des médicaments que les
habitants de kiev aurait absorbé pour se
prémunir me schwartz
hier soir le journal télévisé soviétique
se voulait rassurant en diffusant un
reportage sur la vie quotidienne en
ukraine
douze jours après l'accident de la
centrale de tchernobyl
si l'on en croit les images tournées à
la campagne ou dans la cour d'une école
tout semble aller pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes
ce que confirme un entretien avec un
habitant du cru
il semble que cette vision et vidic est
tranquille ne correspondent pas tout à
fait à la réalité si l'on en croit des
témoignages recueillis à moscou à
l'arrivée des trains en provenance de
kiev même si personne n'a parlé des
paniques certains voyageurs ont été
bloqués l'inquiétude des habitants
une inquiétude qui s'est traduite selon
les autorités soviétiques par de
nombreuses intoxications dues à
l'absorption de médicaments censés
lutter contre les radiations dans le
reportage vinifiant de télévision
soviétique on le traque les mêmes le
contrôle d'un bateau au compteur geiger
mais un contrôle a dit sa mère nature
aliments négatif les 12 euros